the coronavirus has shut down three
orders across the country of course and
the lights have dim on New York's famed
Broadway several actors have tested
positive for the corona virus they
include Broadway veteran Danny Burstein
he's known for his award-winning
performances and musicals like fiddler
on the roof we spoke to Burstein about
his fight against the virus which he
described in a recent essay for The
Hollywood Reporter Broadway veteran
Danny Burstein has earned six Tony
nominations performing in shows like
South Pacific cabaret and playing Tevye
in Fiddler on the Roof he was widely
tipped to earn another this year for his
performance in Moulin Rouge the musical
but in mid-march the coronavirus closed
Broadway and a week later attacked the
actor himself and what did you feel in
the beginning I felt like I had a little
bit of allergies the 55 year old
Burstein who's married to actress
Rebecca lucre says he soon developed a
fever listlessness and crushing
headaches it felt like a migraine on
steroids but it got worse and worse and
worse over the days at one point you
were coughing up blood
yeah I'd been coughing up blood for two
or three days and of course it scared me
but my doctors told me you know just
hang on hang on as long as you're not
having trouble breathing you should be
okay but then while taking a shower I
started to have trouble breathing real
trouble breathing and I fell on my knees
in the shower in the shower they called
out loudly I think I need to go to the
hospital what were you thinking at that
point in I was thinking that I hope I
hadn't waited too long his wife Rebecca
and youngest son Zack helped him get to
Mount Sinai Morningside hospital where
Burstein was isolated in the kovat unit
he wrote that you felt surrounded by
death in the hospital I was I was I
could hear it I was next to the nurse's
station and I heard them talking about
it
I heard them rushing to rooms there was
a someone who would speak over this loud
god Mike and all the nursing staff would
freeze his third day in the hospital
Burstein says was his worst on a trip to
the bathroom he found himself gasping
for breath again and I you know and I'd
had that scary moment in this tiny
little bathroom thinking oh god this is
not the way it's can't end this way
in this stupid bathroom when no one's
gonna know I'm in here he staggered back
to his room and told a nurse and I was
sputtering I couldn't breathe
besides not being able to breathe are
you okay tell you not to panic everybody
was in the same boat exactly and she I'm
sure and I'm sure she'd seen much worse
so her nonchalant attitude made me relax
actually you had a pair of doctors who
had names that you said were very
comforting to you yes one was named dr.
Gandhi and the other ones named dr.
Krishna and they were both kind and
smart and comforting and I greatly
appreciate their expertise after five
days in the hospital Burstein finally
was discharged how did it feel to walk
out the door it felt surreal
like I wasn't sure that it would happen
when I left my apartment building when I
left the lobby I prayed that it wouldn't
be the last time that I was seeing my
lobby do you feel mentally now that
you've been through all this I feel a
little fragile but incredibly grateful
at the same time grateful for my breath
it told me that I'm now immune so
tribulations yeah so I'm like a freakin
superhero you think you'll be back on
Broadway someday hell yes absolutely we
will how we will is yet to be discovered
when I tell you the first the first
night you're back on the stage that's
gonna be a heck of a night it is
is I can't wait and I feel sorry for the
first guy who costs in the audience when
Danny Burstein is back on back on
Broadway rushed to see Danny Burstein
when he's back on Broadway because he's
terrific so is his wife Rebecca lucre
they're both amazing performers and
singers she by the way had the
coronavirus as well not as severely and
she's doing fine now so that's a that's
a recovery story that that is really
nice to hear yes oh Anthony I can't say
enough about Danny Burstein
I can't wait to see him on Broadway on
stage again number one his story was so
descriptive which I liked because we so
take breathing for granted and for him
to spell it out the way he did I felt
like we were all there with him I also
loved how he gave a shout-out to his
doctors kind and gentle and smart just
another reminder about the work that the
people are doing and people like Danny
are surviving because of it oh what a
great great interview